versailles va-t-elle devenir la cité de
la gastronomie française
c'est la question que nous allons poser
au prochaine invitée est due cette suite
un peu de culture partagée je connais
pas de plats traditionnels vers c'est
donc c'est un emblème français
versailles mais après sa gastronomie je
pourrais pas vous dire parce que je
pense que l'aura de versailles le
château et tout ça le côté touristique
l'emportent sur en fait la véritable
qualité gastronomique que peut offrir la
ville gastronomie française il ya des
bons restaurants c'est vrai c'est très
sympathique symbole parce que c'est
versailles et que ça sa renommée
il ya plein de petits coins sympas qu'on
ne connaît pas malheureusement où on les
voit temps en temps quelques guides et
on arrive à les repérer comme ça et on y
va quand on habite à côté sinon
je sais pas quoi vous dire mais pour moi
ça peut être une bonne bonne réponse
symbole la gastronomie française non je
pense pas que c'est assez varié ici je
dirais oui il ya quand même une vrai
savoir faire il ya une vraie tradition
un vrai histoire surtout les boulangers
val boulonnerie après les restaurants il
y en a mais c'est pas le seul endroit
parce qu'il ya plein d'endroits où l'on
mange bien france dont sera complètement
injuste tel juste
donnez le domaine à versailles
non pas spécialement je pense que c'est
plus touristiques de gastro voilà
versailles symbole de la gastronomie
française c'est la question vous l'avez
entendu que nous vous avons posé
aujourd'hui à versailles justement et
cette question que vous l'avons posée
puisqu'il pourrait voir il pourrait il
se pourrait que prochainement voit le
jour la cité de la gastronomie bonsoir
olivier de la faire vous êtes conseiller
général des yvelines vous êtes en charge
de ce projet cité de la gastronomie -
vers ça vous l'avez entendu on est
partagés versailles cité de la
gastronomie tout le monde n'est pas
convaincu
c'est vrai que tout le monde s'interroge
sur sur versailles parce que c'est pas
il ne s'est pas une ville reconnue
aujourd'hui en tant que tel pour sa
gastronomie mais versailles a
créée l'essor de la gastronomie
française puisque la gastronomie est
parti de la cour du roi louis xiv pour
se répandre dans le monde sa a été
l'endroit où on a rassemblé l'ensemble
des et des plats régionaux et qui sait
de versailles que et qu'est partie la
gastronomie française dans le monde
là vous avez déjà bien vendu le dossier
puisqu'on va le préciser on va toujours
préciser pour que ce soit bien clair la
mission française du patrimoine et des
cultures alimentaires a lancé un appel à
candidature pour accueillir cette
fameuse cité de la gastronomie plusieurs
villes y sont répondues ils y ont
répondu vous l'avez compris versa et
puisqu'on en parle elle y ont également
beaune dijon tours
rajhi chevilly larue également et donc
versailles comment vous allez même si
vous avez déjà un petit peu
partiellement répondu à cette question
comment vous allez rivaliser avec des
villes telles que lyon par exemple ou
dijon qui peuvent sembler plus légitime
pour accueillir la cité de la
gastronomie
je crois qu'il faut poser le jeu se
reposer dans le contexte aujourd'hui on
a un problème aussi c'est qu'on a une
belle gastronomie mais on perd des parts
de marché dans le monde pourquoi un
problème de compétitivité c'est certain
un problème aussi d'image
je crois que c'est aussi ça le
l'importance de cette cité la
gastronomie c'est de pouvoir nous donner
les moyens de promouvoir la gastronomie
auprès des français parce que je crois
qu on a aussi un problème là où
aujourd'hui beaucoup de français
consommateur se pose la question de
savoir ce qu'ils mangent et ce que
manger tue non je ne vois pas comment
j'ai tué c'est un moyen de pouvoir avec
cette cité promouvoir un petit peu la
gastronomie française les bienfaits de
la gastronomie française
eh bien pourquoi versailles parce que
versailles et ses 10 millions de
visiteurs parce que versailles on a on a
des sites existants on a le potager du
roi qui est un lieu merveilleux qui a
une histoire à raconter
on a le château qui n'a pas rêvé de
dîner au château ces sont des lieux
magiques et je pense qu'aujourd'hui si
on veut attirer les gens soient en a les
moyens de faire à marne la vallée la
gastronomie et on peut mettre 150 200
millions d'euros sur la table très bien
soit on utilise l'existence qui est
notre cas et c'est ce qu'on veut faire
on a aujourd'hui des moyens pour
recevoir les voeux pour recevoir les
étrangers on a des moyens pour
promouvoir la gastronomie pour
accueillir château au potager du roi par
donc un lieu magique on à la ferme de
gally également qu'un espace de
pédagogie fabuleux voilà on a des sites
aujourd'hui qui existent on à la cour
des senteurs qui va ouvrir bientôt à
versailles
enfin on voit le potager du roi aussi
jolie le site soit il est ce que ça peut
suffire
c'est ce que vous allez mettre en
premier ou non alors il y aura un oral
juste pour montrer le sait le 15 octobre
au 15 octobre on va voir un oral qui va
nous permettre de de montrer un petit
peu tous ces sites est de promouvoir un
petit peu notre notre notre action mais
ce qu'on veut dire vraiment là c'est que
on a à travers versailles notre point
fort c'est vraiment d'avoir une
visibilité internationale soit et
d'avoir une visibilité nationale et à la
fois de rassembler l'ensemble les
cultures alimentaires françaises des
régions de toutes les régions françaises
d'être le carrefour comme ça elle a été
finalement au avant ça a marché la
preuve en est c'est qu'on est le premier
pays reconnus pour notre gastronomie
dans le monde c'est quand même une
vérité on est premier pays touristique
aussi dans le monde c'est aussi une
vérité les le monde entier vient en
france pour visiter et pour vous et pour
manger donc donnons les moyens d'avoir
un site qui permettent de promouvoir
cette gastronomie française qui est
fabuleuse fois qu'on a pas à s'en cacher
même si toutes les autres cultures sont
aussi très bonne mais on a des atouts je
pense qu'il faut qu'on les mette en
avant et on a besoin aujourd'hui en
france de redynamiser un petit peu cette
cette économie qui est une valeur sûre
française en plus de ça et vous ne
manquez pas d'arguments pour défendre
versailles
on l'a bien compris c'est ce que vous
allez exposés à cette mission française
du patrimoine et des cultures
alimentaires le 15 octobre début
décembre il y aura le verdict
on saura si oui ou non versailles
accueillera cette cité de la gastronomie
il ya tout de même un point sur lequel
il faut insister c'est la question du
financement
il ya eu un article récemment un dossier
dans les nouvelles de versailles est le
journal local qui précisait que personne
ne voulait payer
ani le député maire françois de mazières
ni alain schmitz le président du conseil
général 15 à 20 millions seraient
nécessaires françois de mazières qui
vous reprocher aussi un même s'il
soutient le projet de ne pas avoir
trouvé de financement
est ce qu'aujourd'hui ce soir vous allez
me dire qu'il ya des sous et ben oui
nous avons des sous ça y est c'est le
budget est clos on a trouvé les sourds a
été d avec 17 des partenaires privés
donc à la limite on pourrait même monter
un projet sans avoir besoin des
collectivités locales et puis
à voir aussi après à la participation de
l'état comment elle pourrait être je
pense que si l'état a quand même une
mission de service public puisqu'il
s'agit bien de promouvoir l'ensemble de
la gastronomie française et c'est quand
même notre économie nationale
donc à voir avec l'état comment elle
peut aussi par se dire nous aider le
projet je pense que c'est même
indispensable mais aujourd'hui nous
sommes en mesure de voir vous dire avec
des partenaires privés
oui nous pouvons financer le projet tous
les partenaires privés ont signé un
accord ou c'est un engagement
c'est un engagement on est on est on a
monté un dossier en trois mois
très sincèrement on a essayé c'est toute
la complexité des choses avec peu de
moyens de monter un dossier à la hauteur
de ceux des autres et je pense
qu'aujourd'hui on aura on aura un beau
dossier oui on va pas citer de nom on va
pas citer de marque mais c'est donc à
laisser la primeur à comment grands
partenaires des restaurateurs il ya
effectivement des noms il ya des gens du
bâtiment qui vont nous aider des gens du
bâtiment qui vont nous aider mais on a
également moi j'ai eu des retours aussi
d'industriels qui sont prêts aussi à
venir s'installer dans la cité des 4000
parce que ça les intéresse
ddd des chefs qui veulent venir aussi
des restaurateurs qui veulent venir
inquiéter la gastronomie investira
c'était la gastronomie alors certains
ont dit oui nous on veut aller à
versailles parce que on sait très bien
qu'à versailles à un flux et donc ça
nous intéresse c'est vrai que des
millions de visiteurs qui en ont juste à
traverser la route c'est quand même plus
facile que de faire venir sur un autre
site
et puis d'autres disent aujourd'hui nous
on veut pas se prononcer parce qu'on
veut être aussi dans la cité de la
gastronomie des grandes marées c'est
comme ça mais ce qui me paraît tout à
fait légitime donc on verra après
choisissons la ville et puis développons
notre projet et je pense qu'on arrivera
à développer aussi notre budget parce
que aujourd'hui je vous avais sur depuis
que depuis quinze jours on commence à
communiquer son projet chez que des
retours positifs même des grands chefs
qui viennent nous voir pour pour dire on
veut vous aider sur ce projet parce
qu'on y croit
donc c'est plutôt poussé plutôt positif
même des gens de la rade de les radios
des télés qui nous disent mais oui enfin
des gastronomes qui vient nous voir mais
oui votre projet est superbe et je pense
que c'est vrai on a un vrai beau projet
on a besoin de rêver encore aujourd'hui
en france on a besoin de développer des
projets je pense que c'est une belle
occasion de d'utiliser là justement
cette cité la gastronomie pcd cité de la
gastronomie voit le jour ce sera dans
les bâtiments de l'ancienne poste a vu
paris en plein centre-ville examen
centre-ville à servette reste à voir
comment va se dérouler ce grand oral ce
sera le 15 octobre et on essaiera de
vous avoir justement ligne vous nous
ferez un poids vous nous direz comment
ça s'est passé même si j'imagine que
rien ne doit doit transpirer que ça doit
rester un petit peu concurrentiel mais
avec plaisir sera quand même d'en savoir
plus merci d'être venu olivier de la
sphère présenter ce projet de la cité de
la gastronomie
avant de refermer cette édition du 9
octobre nous faisons le point sur les
principaux sujets que nous avons abordé
ce soir ils ont été nombreux soirée de
prestige autour du vélodrome en ce
moment visite de chantier avec la
fédération française de cyclisme qui va
s'installer à saint quentin en yvelines
remise de trophées à des grands noms du
cyclisme au théâtre de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines
vous avez vécu une partie de cette
soirée au cours de ce set 8
manifestation nationale à l'appel de la
cgt pour la défense de l'emploi
industriel
hier les syndicalistes ont déjà été
reçus par le président du conseil
général
vous avez vu que notre journaliste qui
était en ligne avec tous l'un des
responsable local de la cgt qui a évoqué
ses inquiétudes
le maire du chesnay philippe brillault a
fait voter une motion contre le projet
en faveur du mariage homosexuel
il nous a expliqué sa position il a
débattu avec elie les dix huit élus de
carrières sous poissy et puis la nuit
blanche ce n'était pas seulement à paris
elle avait également lieu ce samedi soir
elle encourt entre autres le quartier 17
mar a dévoilé ses talents artistiques
avec le chorégraphe jean claude gallotta
1500 visiteurs étaient présents sur
l'ensemble de l'agglomération de saint
quentin
ce sont les chiffres de la communauté
d'agglomération c'est un reportage que
vous retrouverez dans le tout images de
la rédaction à 20h30
l actu et puis également sur notre site
internet comme toutes nos archives je
vous retrouve demain en direct à 18h il
sera question du festival de la bande
dessinée de buc et de la fête de la
science
excellente soirée sur notre antenne